early on in his career Herrick was known
for being well kind of a dumb player
dude that actually hurt his in-game
decisions worth so bad they became the
stuff of means but despite the memes the
doubters and whatever limitations others
thought he had tarik overcame and fall
and about a team from CS goes weakest
region to the pinnacle of the game the
best job time we've ever seen with the
most difficult run from shirtless
streamer to Major MVP Tarek's journey is
all about growth seal the deal has to
can all be how to get out of this
[Applause]
these days tarik is known as the content
king but he had to work for that
nickname because he started very small
sometimes he literally streamed from his
brothers closet yeah I mean I really
come a long way from where I first
started from my bedroom streaming
shirtless and then going into my
brother's closet in Buffalo and
streaming there shirtless since his very
first foray into streaming tarik was all
about being seen and entertaining his
audience and he wasn't afraid to show a
little bit of skin to do it
no sure TV originally started when I was
playing in this room actually it was
just super hot in my room and I couldn't
take it I was raging and I was just
sweating everywhere and I was like screw
this I'm taking off my shirt it just
became like a norm on my shreem sorta
and I was like hey why don't I just
making my brand back when he was known
as no shirt TV tarik was facing off
against some of any's best players and
online matches and winning not only is
he a good player but he could be very
charismatic on the camera and he could
have some fun alongside it as well but
his gaming prowess and semi nudity
weren't the only things that attracted
the community tarik didn't just play
topless
he also played Tilted well his keyboard
was tilted extremely tilted when I first
started attending lens that space was
very limited so we had to tilt our
keyboards to give more space to our
teammates and then over time I just
started to become more comfortable
playing like that tarik always had a
clear idea of who he was his identity
was firmly rooted in his turkish
heritage his wacky sense of humor and
his passion for gaming but on the server
his moves were anything but clear
why doesn't only not end dude tarik made
so many weird downright dumb decisions
during his matches that he began to be
known as peanut brain in the csgo
community there's been some people I
don't know who they are but they've
accused tarik of having a brain that
resembles like a like a type of nut you
really I call him like a peanut brain or
something yeah so like I like peanut
brain but I was messed up on the other
hand though when tarik was on he was on
[Music]
it was undeniable that Tareq's so-called
peanut brain was capable a lot more than
the insult suggesting it was almost like
tarik has two different modes and his
over-performing alter-ego was quickly
dubbed watermelon brain watermelon brain
tarik performed extremely well under
pressure showing some of the skills that
would eventually make him a pillar of
NACS tarik transition from streamer to
pro came after netcode guys offered him
a contract tarik dropped out of high
school to pursue a gig as a full-time
professional gamer taraf career got off
to a turbulent start net code guides
were wrapped up in one of CS goes
biggest controversy as when I buy power
through a match against them I don't
know what's going on tonight if they're
educated baby jet like I don't know
following the match fixing scandal
though tarik and his teammates emerged
as counter logic gaming first csgo
roster obviously pulling off a hell of a
victory here how does it feel
taking win out land feels amazing
honestly it's not a huge land but
winning against the city makes it just
as much better during is one and a half
year stint with CLG tariffs peaks were
high but the valleys were tarik did
great against any opponent but his
performance against the dominant
European teams was pretty spotty he got
pretty good around MLG Columbus he was
legit on that point in time
the rest of time he's been good against
North Americans he's repeatedly shat the
bed of majors and against European teams
and if time was theology came to an end
after a devastating loss against
Dignitas at ESL one cologne 2016 a match
that tarik and CLG just weren't ready
for maybe you would have thought CLG
would have got some more Rams on the
board wasn't to be on this occasion
however so they will go with their tails
between their legs
after leaving CLG Tara took a break to
return to full-time of streaming which
ought have a lot more room to goof off
than a professional career dead
like looking smooth I'm gonna die I'm
telling you guys right now I'm gonna die
it's good dude now that you see me over
that in August 2016 Tareq rejoined a
professional scene with optic gaming but
it wasn't clear which tarik they were
getting would the peanut brain take
control or would his time with the
roster be dominated by the watermelon
brain blingy and tonic is a great
addition because he's a very skilled
player for north american players of the
north american players I'd have him top
five in terms of raw skill and it shows
of what you can actually do in the
server
well tarik was part of the team's more
significant victories even helping optic
earn a reputation as one of the best
teams in na it wasn't all butterflies
and rainbows our communication is a big
problem right now make sure everyone's
talking and once we figure out our
communication issues I think that's the
biggest thing right now
after Stanislaw the team's igl left for
Team Liquid optics roster slowly
crumbled and ESL one cologne 2017 was
the last time Terra crept the green wall
before trading it in for cloud nines
blue to put it great and I think it's
boosted our confidence up a lot and our
team works looking good I'm hopeful for
the future of this round but in true
tarik fashion the transitional wasn't
without its hiccups play look good
tomorrow I don't know about that oh my
god I'm tripping bro I'm not even on
optic bro what am i doing what am i
doing bro how nine games Heric the
opportunity to try out a new role a few
weeks after joining the roster he became
the team's IgM Tareq's ambition led c9
to victory at the Boston major in 2018
marking na s first ever major win in a
truly iconic moment in eSports history
this has to be one of the most
incredible
we've ever had a North American team in
North America with the major win but in
the world of csgo even major winning
rosters don't last forever maybe he just
peaked with c9 or maybe it's just that
Marat sir shuffles really are inevitable
but tariff is ready for a new challenge
I'm joining MIB are to win and we are
going to win and that's the reason I'm
here
MIB are marked a bit of a career low for
tearing after Boston nothing else could
come close and he didn't exactly gel
with his team a team I'm elated teriyaki
so lucky were you at all because the
[ __ ] streamer youtuber and I mean
like he'd just not playing that good but
after only five months in the active
lineup he chose to remain on MIB hours
of bench contemplating his next big move
many people wrote Tara calls he was a
has been whose 15 minutes of fame were
over matera Mr content himself continued
to put out videos for his fans like
nothing was wrong chick is such a
talented and promising gamers it would
be a shame if you would not get back on
track down whoever wrote that shout-out
to the boy did shoutouts as a boy he
actually cares in fact it didn't take
long for tarik to get back in the game
he joined NRG in February and when he
loaded onto the server for his new team
peanut brain was nowhere to be found
we have to get out of there
[Applause]
well peanut-brained didn't show up most
of the time this defense is just getting
overrun apex is already in the site he's
got to do this he's got to do it on the
trigger discipline he gets anything
nothing at all for Terry and nothing at
all for NRG and by September evil genius
has picked up Energy's roster Terra
concluded just in time for ESL one New
York the newly minted eg took on a
strong as the number one csgo team in
the world and brought them down three to
one
[Applause]
some people might have called the win a
fluke but the fact is eg did what team
liquid then the second best csgo team in
the world failed to accomplish earlier
in the tournament that can't be a
coincidence compared to the competition
V's lineup looks middling on paper and
yet they're doing remarkably well the
team is consistently over performing and
their stock is rising fast whether it's
a winning combination of skills or AG's
eagerness to prove themselves on the
world stage it seems that the often
inconsistent eric has finally found his
groove I didn't expect him to kill
absolutely everybody in the first round
of the map and that's true of his
teammates two players who often didn't
have a lot to show for their time the
professional arena at least not until
now everyone on that team they weren't
really a big high pot player so they
were individually skilled very talented
but you didn't have someone who was like
the motivating boosting factor what
tarik brings is that loudness that
confidence he'll try and scream and
shout and get into the heads of other
players they're easy top their group at
ESL pro league season 10 America's
leaving carrots former team cloud nine
in the dust two to zero any G's win
against fnatic at starseries i League
really solidified ter its current roster
as a force to be reckoned with proving
to the non-believers that eg are more
than capable of going toe-to-toe with
pretty much anyone eg a are having a lot
of success but they're also attending
more events than what your Australis and
what your Team Liquid are and that can
also have a negative in some way so
depend how it pans out it's hard to say
what the future holds for Terry if his
current performance is anything to go by
he'll continue to blossom as a player
who constantly defies the label slap on
him by others from dropping out of high
school at 18 to winning the biggest
prize that csgo has to offer from peanut
brain to water melon brain Eric's
transformation has been truly remarkable
will tarik ever be able to match his
historic achievement at the Boston major
he might but the beauty of it is that he
doesn't have to tarik already helped put
CS goes biggest losers the NA region on
the map and not a bite of cereal was
missed in the
process do you that you think with me
mean to the door [ __ ] you door I never
loved you
they asked you how you are you just have
to say that you're fine and you're not
really fine but you just can't get into
it because they would never understand